hey youtubers it's Charlie this is going
to be my flash season 3 video just
careful for spoilers if you haven't seen
the season 2 finale yet we'll be talking
about all kinds of stuff especially from
legends of tomorrow so careful for
spoilers from that - the writers have
already started working on season 3
there are a couple things that we know
they're going to do gorilla grodd
foregone conclusion that he's going to
come back and they're going to tease
more gorilla City we might see Sola bar
there are also a lot of villains from
the Flash's rogues gallery we haven't
seen yet they had originally teased
mirror master before season 2 started
but I guess they decided not to do him
so he's just a good example of a rogue
that they could do in season 3 that's
really big there would be a lot of fun
but if you are wondering why they
decided not to do mirror master I think
it has to do with the concept of the
mirror universe they just they didn't
want to get into that because it was so
weird and they were already doing
speedforce wormhole aliens so we'll
continue to push into that very and team
flash have barely started to learn about
what the Speed Force is how it works all
the particular x' we haven't even gotten
to the idea of the negatively-charged
speed force that's an eel bard dawn
thing they'll always be eobard thawne in
the flash he's the Flash's greatest
nemesis so of course they're never going
to get rid of him there are two
takeaways that I had from the finale
beyond the flashpoint twist of him
preventing his mother from being
murdered
so one when he says you're never going
to hurt my mother again you can't really
tell whether or not he kills the
reverse-flash even if he didn't kill him
he altered the timeline so much neither
one of them should have Speed Force
powers but number two if he really did
lose the Speed Force he's going to be
stuck in the past which feels like a
lesser possibility because then they
could do trial of the flash but how
would they explain Barry Allen being in
prison for all those years in what's
going to happen to young Barry when he
grows up and starts looking like older
Barry it just gets really complicated so
I think they'll find a way logically to
get the flashback to the future but he
will find a very different future that
he came back to so while I do like the
idea of them doing trial of the flash
and if you're not familiar with that
storyline it's just that in the Silver
Age comics you bar Thawne was obsessed
with iris West she was like an object of
affection she wasn't quite as good of a
character she's in the modern comics so
here bar Thawne is like I want her she
should be mine but if I can't have her
I'm gonna kill her so to stop him from
killing iris Barry has to snap his neck
but then a twist is
he has to stand trial for murdering
another person even if that person was
the reverse-flash so that's one
possibility when they come back but I
like the idea that he goes back to a
future that is just radically different
from the one that he left and that's the
flashpoint arc in a lot of people have
been a little confused about this
they're like hey wait they can't do
Batman how they going to do flashpoint
if they can't do Batman or Wonder Woman
no we're talking about the TV shows
version of flashpoint
so remember what happens during
flashpoint Berry goes back in time
prevents his mother from being murdered
but it radically alters the future
that's flashpoint finding out that his
mother needs to die that it's important
for history that his mother does die so
he has to come to terms with that and is
this big psychological journey for him
so that'll be a big story point for
season three and I know a lot of you
have complained that hey didn't Barry
already come to that conclusion it was
okay that his mother had died because
she loves him she'll always love him
even in death so it seemed like he'd
come to terms with that but I guess just
the double whammy of his father dying
right after that which is too much for
him so the greatest drama of the show
will always be created by the main
characters mistakes by the mistakes that
they make but on the lighter side of
things Jay Garrick everybody is like
what's going to happen with Jay Garrick
in season 3 he went back to earth 3 but
he's totally going to come back to the
show of course they're not going to
crown John Wesley Shipp as Jay Garrick
and not let him come back to have some
fun so because he's such a big part of
Justice Society
I expect that they'll start to tease
that out a little bit but getting into
legends of tomorrow crossover stuff
because they're going to do a big
four-way cross over that will clearly be
tied to a Justice Society arc no matter
how big or small they decide to let it
be you have to remember that most of the
main characters on all their shows are
still becoming their best selves they're
still in the process of evolution so
even though Supergirl is really powerful
and they might tease Justice Society
she hasn't evolved to her just to
society self I mean if all these shows
end up running for seven seasons
obviously arrow is going to end a little
bit sooner than the other shows because
they started a couple years after but I
feel like you know by the time we get to
the very end of some of these shows we
will see the actual Justice Society
you'll see the old stars come back like
Stephen Amell if arrow ends at seven
seasons but the other shows go a couple
more
after that you'll see him come back and
guest star when they do Justice Society
stories but because they're teasing
Justice Society I think when they do
their big four-way crossover they'll do
like a big Jay Garrick type payoff where
you see a version of them all standing
together around that big table and what
it might end up looking like but if
you're wondering why they put Jay
Garrick on earth three it's just to
explain why he's not around every single
week otherwise like if he were living
down the street from Barry you'd be like
how come we don't see him this week
what's he doing the speaking of which
Jesse quick Wally West Harrison wells
what's going on with them totally expect
them all to be back next season they
haven't announced Jesse quick or Wally
West as cast regulars I think so we
might not see them in every single
episode of all those people I'm
expecting that Tom Cavanagh will remain
main cast so we'll see Harrison wells in
every episode
maybe not Jesse quick she might just
come back for a couple episodes maybe
half the episodes she's a really big
character and I think everybody wants
her back so I think they're gonna try
and use her as much as they can within
whatever story arc they decide to go
with I think the first half of the
season will be consumed with Barry
fixing his mistake dealing with the
consequences of saving his mother the
second half of the season will probably
be more focused on who the big bad is
going to be but what about the big
villain there's still a couple really
evil speedsters they could get into I
think you know Barry will be the
antagonist he'll be his own antagonist
for the first half of the season like oh
my god I can't believe I did this how do
I fix it but they will have a real built
like an actual villain the Barry can
punch in the face by the end of the
season so I know they tease the black
flash in the finale but I think it's a
little too soon to bring him back so if
we do see him again
we'll just see shades of that he won't
be like the main villain they're not
going to bring him right back but we'll
definitely see Gorilla Grodd he'll be a
villain but he's a little too expensive
to do like it's really expensive to do
gorilla grodd episodes because of the CG
that if they really want to go with
another speedster villain they could
either go with an evil version of max
mercury because there's so much mercury
lab stuff they've done but talking about
the multiverse of course they're going
to do more multiverse stuff they just
teased earth 3 course we'll probably see
shades that or at least learn a little
bit more about it but wouldn't it be
awesome if they did crime syndicate now
I know a lot of people are confused
because when they said Jay Garrick is
from earth 3 everyone's like hey wait a
minute isn't that crime scene
the kid earth wouldn't he be Johnny
quick if he were the flash of earth
three so remember the TV show kind of
did earth to as crime syndicate earth
bunch of evil versions of the characters
but they didn't really do crime
syndicate so I do like the idea that
they'd push into the multiverse with
respect to the villain and that would be
an easy path to seeing more evil
versions of the characters that were
distinct from the earth to evil
characters like we saw killer frost
she's an evil version of Caitlyn I think
we'll see more killer frost but in a
roundabout way because earth to Caitlyn
is dead but the other twist is the idea
that we could see a villain manifest
directly from the Speed Force there's so
much that we don't know about the way
the TV show is going to use it now we
can talk about it in the comics but
there have been a number of times
especially in DC rebirth where
characters just emerge from the Speed
Force after having been trapped there
there have also been rumors that the big
villain is not going to be a metahuman
is just going to be a normal person or
at least a super-smart person so they go
that route we could see a non powered
version of a big flash villain like we
haven't seen inertia yet typically he's
a speedster villain like he has speed
force powers he's from the future but
because the TV show mixes and matches
things from different characters and
different villains like zoom was an
amalgam of hunter zolomon from the
comics with the Jay Garrick character
I'm expecting them to do the same thing
again but they could just do that with a
metahuman like we could see a version of
the rival or a version of inertia that
doesn't have powers and has a slightly
different name but let me know in the
comments what kind of big bad do you
want to see them use and if they do
decide to use someone that doesn't have
powers who do you think the villains
going to be but just to get into more
Justice Society stuff there will be some
villain crossover across all the shows
just just for that four-way crossover
episode but the legends of tomorrow
villain who will be the big bad of you
know whatever that big crossover is is
supposed to be way worse than Vandal
Savage one big bad that's a little bit
bigger than Vandal Savage would be more
drew they could totally do him on
legends of tomorrow so let me know in
the comments on top of whatever big bad
the flash season 3 main villain is who
do you think the big Justice Society
team-up villain is going to be but just
a reminder they're already working on
season 3 of the flash right now all the
other TV shows really have gone back to
work so
we might start hearing a few things all
the stars have started to say a few
things a lot of them don't really know
exactly what's going to be happening
next season yet Stephen Amell was like I
don't know how much Berry's derp is
going to affect our show but I'm
expecting the flash flash point arc to
remain largely self-contained like it'll
change a lot of the relationships on the
flash people might not think of Barry in
the same way who's the flash we've never
heard of that person before but it's not
going to completely reset the plotline
of air so it's not going to negate all
the stuff that's happened on arrow or
even legends of tomorrow for that matter
but they will have to address it in a
minor way but I know it sounds a little
complicated now they'll explain more as
we get closer to comic-con and we see
the actual trailers like well we'll get
a teaser for what's actually going to
happen in the first couple of episodes
of the flash and that'll largely explain
how they're going to be addressing
Barry's big derp so real quick reminder
there's a new round of the DC giveaway
that starts now all you have to do to
enter is be a subscriber and leave a
comment on this video is basically going
all week I'll announce the winner in the
next DC video that I post I am going to
see x-men apocalypse tonight so I'll
finally be able to post my non-spoilery
review of that then I'll do an Easter
Egg video and I'm still working on a
preacher video for episode 1 it airs
after fear The Walking Dead on Sunday
nights alright so I think it's replacing
fear The Walking Dead because that's on
hiatus for now but lots of awesome comic
book stuff happening this summer it's
going to be great preachers actually a
really good show so while you guys wait
for my next video to post you can click
here for my flash finale video and you
can click here for my arrow finale video
thank you so much for watching everybody
let's high five I'll see you guys
tonight
you